after those boys the old boys got us going let's
see if the young guys see what they got it's time
now for the Zack be opening PP drop and here
we go home opener for 23 24 nice play by Tyson
Barry the only man back now the Predator chip in
go here's Jeremy Lozan off to Glass glass on the
back hand got the shot away save B tried to hit
the back door wield back to the net by dun didn't
get there mdun tried to clear Fe to the slot Donna
shot rebound loose in front and S passes on it SC
scramble in front we'll take a look here did that
get through or did that it it got through it got
through he lost it and then he was trying to fight
to find that puck just battling cier right here in
front of the net that scrambles it hits him and he
juice finds that puck gets some good help see MCD
sitting in there behind Soros and we're so used
to watching Romanos SK through literally everybody
yeah he just wants to do it all on his own well
now he's he's they're trying to get everyone
involved glass a dynamic move at Center good pass
into to Cole Smith the wrist shot kick save guau I
love this attack the middle kick it to the outside
spread these guys out and then Cole Smith with a
shot I think he's looking for a rebound there to
side bosi quickly looks for a play alexc Center
Point the shot Ricochet wide picked up alexc got a
man open the shot stopped by Soros quick as a cat
look at this eyes on Puck Here Comes bosi Saros
with a Golden Glove Kraken came here late last
year for a two game series if you will and they
split with Nashville another good save for Sorrows
the rebound block high slot no back has it looks
quickly up ice sends it back Nashville in a line
CH now trying to accelerate Barry slowed down by
G out High Quist on the four check with Cole Smith
Here Comes glass Smith to the point good feed
Barry he's a shooter to the high slot backand
by glass and a great save by gr BAU in Tampa but
he's back there again and makes a nice play here
almost sneaks that backand but I love the the way
they're moving the puck up and over spreading the
Zone again getting that that beat into the middle
former Edmonson oer feads it through the middle
done to Everly the shot slowed down in front loose
in the slot taken by glass over to the sideboards
it doesn't get out po Smith harasses his man
mccan and goes off to the bench and we have a
whistle Story of My Life step 75 stepy 75 that's
right the stairs are counted Nashville starts the
second period on the power play that's lifted
out of play was it deflective well the PRS are
pointing Yosi and here come the officials this
could be a delay of game 44 seconds to go in
the five on three stick drop on the ice Larson
doesn't have it trying to go back and get it
Nashville reloads it's Barry Waits shoots safe
B rebound and a kick save on the followup by
guau great action Barry just launching that shot
and here's Barry right there look he he gets the
killers to bite they back in obviously it's five
on three guow just gets enough of it long stretch
of action end to end with no whistles now Jaden
Schwarz leaves it for Gore give and go guided to
the net sticked aside by Soros Yamamoto getting
a chance on the power play unit number two York
Strand had his pass stolen by Cole Smith right up
the scene charging after it sist he's got it he
[Music] scores shorthanded goal in Dynamic fashion
Smith with the steel siss with the tuck it's one
nothing Nashville on home mice here in smashville
goals to col assistence and look at the work there
by Cole Smith just chips that puck to the middle
and sistence wins the battle here gets that net
front stays on his feet and then lifts the puck
backand over gau's right pad in the back of the
net one nothing PRS trenen shot off the back w
glass beating the cut back toward Yosi oh what
a save by grow Yosi snuck in the back door he
had a lot of net to shoot out Nashville has the
lead Yosi tried to double it that's a big save my
good they almost did get another one right before
the break that great save by gral Nashville
has it back here's another great pass fa Ro
to forsberg and he is stopped by gr bow yosi's
in the flank is a one-time they they love the
ability to create Angelisa and thomasino trying
to do just that iist just missed the net rebound
wrap around triy by Evangelista stopped by gr
bow with the short-handed goal the only tally
of the game from the Kraken trying to build
their own momentum Schwarz out to Schulz that
one into a host of bodies banged off of one of
them before got the stups Here Comes Ryan mcdunn
to the neet front cut off by guau rebound
Tren got the shot away rubow on it row has
been sharp here in the second period Nashville
still with it to the slot trenen stick tied up
picked up on the near Side by ker left it for
Parson on the doorstep fading back ker open man
mcdunn carier a lot of bodies in front turning
around ten and stopped a spin move in tight
quarters third period about to begin assistance
will take the draw Nashville has won 66% of the
faceoffs exactly 2/3 2412 including 10 out
of 12 quick regroup bers into the Zone again
pushed over to the wall by krier played ahead
to forsberg forsberg up the ice makes the move
to the middle candra stop oh what a dynamic move
by forsberg bonus time here in the six on five
MCD the pump fake carrier to Nyquist nist no
look pass he scor it's backed [Music] in on
the delayed penalty the Predators double the
lead they kept the pressure on Nyquist fired
it right towards the net and this team Works
they don't give up they look at that second
effort by Ryan O'Reilly to get the puck back
to the point and look at the Pu movement up
to the top it it's just so calm they've got the
extra attacker on and what does night twist do
he goes right to the front of the net Banks it in
Brian O'Reilly this is off is that go off Philip
forsberg and then Duman Yosi managed to get it
to Parson him somehow Fabro goes for the long
bomb he's got Evangelista bouncing Puck Luke has
it evisa is stuck by goow oh what a pretty pass
that was FB couldn't it there perfectly look
at this stretch pass this the flip just get it
up and over all your attackers that only works
if you knows someone's blowing out the backside
Evangelista jumps on it and watch Evangelista
he gets grar to do what he wants he Fades away
dried that diagonal feed right through the box
York Strand straight away no look shot by D Dax
block that one off the post rebound loose and sent
back into the corner asille got a little Lu from
the post now windberg makes a dynamic move gets
in but then fans on the shot Falling Down is Fabro
and then Fanning on the shot on the other side
was Yamamoto now to the empty Net score person
[Music]
it the youngster from Finland dialed
long distance and nville takes a three
nothing lead game when we talk about
the maturity for such a young player
he's out there in the last two minutes
most crucial part of the game right
watch him get the puck looks once and
just ices it right [Applause] [Music]
down and year 25 starts with
a shut out from UC Soros